welcome to Horry subs the channel will
be discussed the latest tech news and
dove into newest tech products so the
gtx 1180 is going to cost $700
so is that price actually worth it or is
nvidia just being greedy but before we
delve into that make sure to hit that
subscribe button if you guys like to
stay updated with the latest tech news
related to gaming and pcs the gtx 1180
has been anticipated for a very long
time now and according to the latest
leak from gamer milled which is from an
insider third-party variant card
manufacturer that gtx 1180 is actually
coming very soon as a next month on july
30th
if you guys are interested in the
details of that leak then make sure to
check out my dedicated video on it but
anyways the gtx 1180 was always expected
launch for an MSRP of $700 but now that
we are closer to launch and we have more
information about the performance and
specs of the gtx at 1180 is the gtx 1180
actually worth $700 well to answer that
question we first have to take a look at
the expected specs of the gtx 1180
and while the specs aren't mind-blowing
or anything the gtx 1180 is definitely
going to be a solid significant upgrade
over the gtx 1080 according to the
latest leak from WCC after tech the gtx
1180 is supposed to have 3584 cuda cores
with a base clock of 1600 megahertz and
a boost clock of 1800 megahertz and
according to gamer meld the gtx 1180
will come with 8 gigabytes of memory
which will probably do ddr 6 memory and
it'll be on the 12 nanometer process and
based on the turing architecture finally
it will have a TDP of 170 to 200 watts
so as you guys can see the gtx 1180 is
basically a more efficient version of
the gtx 980ti
with higher clock speeds and some little
perks like gt-r 6 memory and a tall
nanometer process and so those little
improvements on the gtx 1180 over the
gtx 980ti
will most likely lead to an about a 20
frames per second increase over the
performance
the gtx 980ti for the gtx 1180 so
basically you are getting better
performance on the GTX 10 atti for the
same MSRP of $700 on top of this the gtx
1180 may come with tents of course and
ray-tracing technology which will just
further enhance the performance also
according to gamer mode the gtx 1180 is
supposed to support DirectX 12.5 and
DirectX 13 and this may be the new API
for ray tracing technology so the
performance difference between the gtx
1180 and the gtx 1080p ID may be a lot
more than just 20 frames per second so
as you guys can see the gtx 1180 is
definitely worth the price of $700
besa is going to bring a solid upgrade
over the gtx 980ti while costing the
same amount something else to remember
is that at launch the GTX 1080 also
costed $700 so this is not something new
for Nvidia so it is clear that the gtx
is indeed worth its price of $700 but
just because it is a good deal doesn't
mean that it is still worth it for you
so it's the gtex 1180 worth it for you
guys well in my opinion probably not
because most of you guys can't even take
advantage of all the performance that
the gtx 1180 will come with if you are
gaming at 1080p and just want a solid 60
frames per second electrode detail for
the next couple of years on all games
then the GTX 1160 will be the perfect
card for you because it will provide a
lot more performance and you need still
and on top of that it will significantly
be better than the GTX 1060 while
costing the same at $250 so that's a lot
cheaper than $700 while still getting
really good performance if you are
looking for a graphics card for ultra
wide 1080p gaming or 1440p gaming and
the best card for you would be the GTX
1170 which will most likely just have
better performance in the GTX 1080
but at the same time it'll have the same
MSRP as the gtx 1070 so why am I telling
you all this well I don't want you guys
to get the false impression that there
is no point to wait for the GTX 1100
series anymore
because the 1180 is so expensive and it
is more performers than you need in the
first place
because there are also a lot of
budget-friendly options coming with the
1100 series which will provide you with
more performance than what you are
getting with the 10 series right now for
the same price so for all of you guys I
really recommend that you guys just wait
for the 1100 series it is coming out so
soon and even if you don't want the gtx
1180 the gtx at 1180 is really for
people who want really good 4k
performance or the best performance
available on the mainstream platform so
if you're in that vote then the gtx 1180
is perfect for you and you can rest
assured that you are not overpaying for
it and that it is completely worth its
price so what do you guys think about
this do you guys think that the gtx 1180
should have been priced less in order to
make it more accessible or do you think
that it isn't well priced and well worth
the - make sure to comment down below
what you guys think because I do read
all my comments and I'm curious as to
what you guys thinks and make sure to
post your thoughts also if you guys like
this video then make sure to drop a like
and hit that subscribe button if you
guys would like to see more videos just
like this one but until next time bye